in terms of advice i forgot to ask
about just machine learning and deep
learning for people who are specifically
interested in
machine learning how would you recommend
they get into the field
so
i would say implement everything and
also there is plenty of courses
so like from scratch um so on different
levels of abstraction in some sense but
i would say implement something from
scratch or implement something from a
paper or implement something you know
from podcasts that you have heard about
i would say that's a powerful way to
understand things so it's often the case
that you read the description and you
think you understand
but you truly understand once you build
it
then you actually know what really meant
that in the description
is there particular topics that you find
people just
fall in love with so i i've seen
i tend to uh really enjoy reinforcement
learning
because it's it's much more
it's much easier to get to a point where
you feel like you created something
special
like like fun games kind of things that
are rewarding it's rewarding yeah
as opposed to like
uh re-implementing from scratch
more like supervised learning kind of
things it's it's yeah so you know
if if someone would optimize for things
to be rewarding then it feels that the
things that are somewhat generative they
have such a property so yes you have for
instance yes adversarial networks or you
have just even generated uh language
models
and you you can even see
internally we have seen this thing with
our releases so we have a we released
recently two models there is one model
called dali that generates images and
there is other model called clip that
actually uh
you provide
various possibilities what could be the
answer to what is on the picture and it
can tell you which one is the most
likely okay
and in some sense in case of the
first one dali
it is very easy for you to understand
that actually there is magic going on uh
and in the in case of the second one
even though it is insanely powerful and
you know people from uh vision community
they as they started probing it inside
they actually understood
how far it goes it's difficult for
person at first to see
how well it works
and that's the same as you said that in
case of supervised learning models you
might not kind of see
or it's not that easy for you to
understand the the strength
even though you don't believe in magic
to see the magic we'll see that magic if
it's a generative that's really
brilliant so anything that's generative
because then you are
at the core of the creation you get to
experience creation
without much effort unless you have to
do it from scratch but and it feels that
you know humans are wired there is some
level of reward for creating stuff yeah
like of course different people have a
different weight on this reward yeah
in a big objective function in the big
objective
of a person
you